hello everyone here at free code cap
i hope you are ready for this video it's
going to be a super exciting one
that personally i have been looking
forward to sharing with you
for a long time it's exciting for
two reasons one i'm gonna be introducing
to you a new technology that makes
creating games
super easy allowing us to spin up games
like
this in minutes two i'm going to be
using this technology
to show you how to create some classic
games such as mario zelda
and space invaders step by step so that
you can have your own game to
take improve on share with your friends
barista
yoga instructor whoever you wish so
before we get to that let's start with
the reason number one
the new technology for those of you who
haven't heard of me my name is anyakubo
and i'm a software developer
and course creator on youtube who love
to teach through building games
and this specific technology is built
exactly for
that we are going to be learning how to
use kaboom
js kaboom.js is a javascript library
that helps you make games
fast we are going to be using this
library to simplify creating scenes
adding layers creating sprites directly
in the project
or importing them based on your
preference dealing with actions and
collisions
adding key events debugging and so much
more
this simplicity allows us to enter the
world of
game development at a low barrier of
entry
and gets us coding without being
disheartened due to pages and pages of
documentation
which is common in the game development
process we see today
the ability to spin up games so quickly
is something that the folks at replit
the collaborative
browser-based ide have been passionate
about developing for quite
some time they wanted the end product to
empower everyone from kids to beginner
devs
as well as intermediate programmers to
start creating games with
as small a learning curve as possible
great now that we have learnt a little
bit about kaboom js
let's get to using it in the next
section i'm going to go over the basic
concepts of kaboom js
i'm going to show you how to import
kaboom js and get it up and running
initialize the project start the game
add
a scene create some sprites as well as
show you all the other things we can do
with it
once we have the basics we will be using
this knowledge to create our three
games as well as learn more things along
the way
if you do need to refer to a section of
the video
after we have learnt a concept please
refer to the time stamps in the
description of this video
each time stamp will take you directly
to the section
annotated next to it now i do advise
that you
not skip ahead of some sections of this
course as the chapters are done
in such a way that will build on the
knowledge you gain throughout
the only prerequisite i ask of you is to
have a basic understanding of the
fundamentals of javascript before
starting this course
but if you're feeling adventurous please
do have a go of following along anyway
like i said this library is intended to
make javascript
coding a whole bunch easier by providing
a layer of
shortcuts if you will to create games
i for one i'm super excited about what
you all end up building with this
javascript library so please
do share your final games with me and
with us
on twitter youtube instagram wherever
you wish
okay so what are we waiting for let's do
this
okay so first things first in this
section
i'm going to show you some of the basics
into getting started with kaboom.js
here are all the functions and methods
to your disposal in the kaboom.js
library i will be covering the core
concepts
so all the ones in red in this section
the others we will learn along the way
while coding our games
by the end you should have a firm
understanding of kabum
and what you can create with it
okay so to start things off i'm actually
going to start off on the kaboom
js website i'm starting off here because
it has
all the documentation that you're going
to need to refer to
after this course so if you do get stuck
or perhaps you just want to do some
extra reading this
is the place to go to now
to get started i'm going to actually
utilize the kaboom environment on replit
which has been pre-made for us
and configured in order to get going a
lot faster
so i'm just going to gravitate toward
there now i'm going to click here on
kaboom environment on replit
and i'm just going to sign up now please
take your time
signing up here i'm just going to click
on the
gmail sign and it's going to take me
straight to my
dashboard fantastic
so here you will see some rebels i've
already made
however i'm going to show you how to
make one from scratch
all you need to do and you can use all
different languages as well
but however so i'm just going to click
here as this is a kaboom js tutorial we
are of course going to choose
kabum so i'm just going to click now and
you will see a lovely
random name has been generated for my
project
now feel free to change this if you wish
i quite like it so i'm just going to
keep it
and click create repel and there we are
our kaboom environment is now loaded
so as i said this has been already
configured
for us the only thing i'm going to ask
you to do is click
here and check there you are on version
5.
if you are not and there is a newer
version out there then don't worry
feel free to code along however if you
do find that something is not working
quite as you would expect
then make sure to change it to version 5
and refer to the documentation to see
what has changed
since this tutorial great
now i just want to cover the basics
these basics are going to be things that
we're going to use
throughout all three tutorials which is
why i think it's great to cover them now
together
the first i'm going to show you how to
do is add a sprite
so let's do it to add a sprite
in replit we have this really cool
feature that will allow us to actually
create
a sprite in the platform itself
this is great as we don't have to rely
on a third-party service such
as a pixel maker or just sort of an
editing
software for images we can make
everything right here
so to do this i'm just going to click
here and what shall we call our sprite
i'm just going to call him her player
and put width and height
of 40. so now i'm just gonna create my
player
um so i'm just going to go ahead and do
that now let's make
them purple and then i'm just going to
make a little alien
because i think that's quite fun so
here's my little
alien um
there we go he looks a little bit like
monster munch if you know that was
crisps
so there we go there's my alien i'm
getting
some little eyes
there they are great so now if i click
main and i am simply going to use the
kaboom method of
add open up some parenthesis open up an
array
and i am simply going to use another
kabum method
called sprite and i'm going to pass the
string
of whatever i called my sprite so
i'm just gonna go like that and click
run
and there we go we have added a sprite
to our game board
that was pretty easy and pretty painless
we can do a lot of
other things too so if i think my sprite
is too big i can scale them by
0.5 and click run
so there we go they are now half the
size i can also use position
so i can position my sprite and the
first value is going to be the x-axis
and the second is going to be the y-axis
all stemming from this point right here
so if i put 20 20 well
our sprite is going to appear right
there
because i've applied 20 pixels to the
left and 20 pixels
from the top so pretty painless
let's carry on the next i'm going to
show you how to do is add a level
so to do this i'm going to use another
kaboom method
called add level making sure that it's
camel case
i'm going to open up a parenthesis and
open up our braces
sorry square brackets so the first
argument is going to be our map
and the second argument is going to be
an object which is going to be our
config for our game
so let's start off with the map first
i'm simply going to draw out what i want
my map to look like
using uh quote marks so there we go i'm
just going to use the quote marks
like so i don't know how many we want
but let's okay let's just have this many
and then i'm going to make x's for the
ground
so make sure that it's in the quote
marks
now we need our config let's also put
something here okay so this
there we go now we need our config so
the width
and the height are going to be the width
and the height of every one of these
little objects here
so i'm going to put 40 and height 40
as well just to be um the same as these
sprites
and now i need to define what all these
objects are
so i'm going to grab the x and this is
the syntax
i'm going to open up my square brackets
and this
x is going to be the sprite
of and then let's make a ground
sprite so once again width and height 40
i'm going to create and then let's make
our ground
so my ground is going to be i can even
add more colors if i wish but i'm pretty
happy with these
there we go so we made our ground so now
i'm going to use ground so once again
i'm just going to use the string of
ground and click run
and there we go we have added our ground
this is looking great the next thing i
want to
do now i think we should apply gravity
to the sprite
so i could do so easily by using body
like so and clicking run
and there he goes he falls with gravity
we have just applied
gravity to the sprite
but obviously we don't want him to fall
through we want him to fall on the
ground right that makes sense
so i can now assign the component solid
to the ground
just like so and he stops
now let's add an enemy so i've decided
that i want anything
with the at sign to be an enemy so let's
grab the enemy
and then i'm gonna use so we're gonna
have to make another sprite that's gonna
be the enemy um
i'm not quite sure what enemy we're
going to have
so i'm just going to create
a little enemy i'm not sure what an
enemy looks like
so i'm just going to create something
um of course feel free to
take your time with this i'm just going
to create a little
bumblebee thing because you know
for some reason i think bumblebees are
now
enemies don't be deceived by their cute
little looks
and let's give it a little face
so there we go there's my little enemy
now so i'm going to use enemy
like so and click run
so we've added our enemy i can have as
many
enemies as i wish on the board so i'm
just going to click run again
and there you go so i don't actually
want that many let's just keep one
for this tutorial and perhaps let's
scale them down so i can apply
scale here too to scale 0.5
brilliant okay so we've added our sprite
we've created our game board the next
thing i want to show you
is how to move a little sprite across
the boot
so to do this i'm going to have to
assign this to something so i can keep
reusing it
in our code so let's perhaps assign this
to
const layer
now using key down
i'm going to pass through right and then
pass through what i want to happen
if i press the right arrow on our
keyboard so what i want to happen
i'm just going to function
so when we press right this is going to
happen this function is going to be
called
so what i want to happen is i want to
grab the player
i want to use the kaboom method of move
and
once again just like with position i'm
going to pass through an x and y
axis um let's save this as move speed
let's make it 200. so we can reuse this
in our code
so i want to i want this to be the
x-axis and i don't want a sprite to move
up or down
i only want them to move left or right
so that is what i've done here by
passing a value to the x-axis of 200
and 0 to the y-axis so now if we run
this and i'm just going to press the
right button
there it goes and there it goes
so now i can actually copy this
and do the left and for left
i simply need to put a minus so that it
goes the other way
on the x axis so now
there we go our sprite is moving
left and right i can also use key press
the choice is totally up to you
now we've covered how to make a sprite
we've covered how to add the
level we've covered how to move our
sprite i'm going to show you one last
thing before we move on and that is what
happens when
two things collide so i'm going to do
that down here
i'm going to grab our player and if he
collides so this is another coupon
method
with anything with the tag of dangerous
so i'm just gonna add the dangerous tag
let's make this perhaps a little bit
dangerous
tag to our enemy so we can reuse this
tag we can put this to
a lot of different sprites but i'm just
going to give it to the enemy for now
so if our player collides with anything
with the tag
dangerous well what do i want to happen
let's pass through a function i want
a player to be destroyed so let's
do that now let's also perhaps add
gravity to the
enemy
and if our player collides with anything
with the tag of
dangerous well i want to destroy it
so i'm going to use the method of
destroy and just pass through our player
so let's run that now
both of them fall i crash into the ferry
and i disappear
my little sprite gets destroyed
great so we have definitely covered all
the basics that need we need to get
started on our tutorials please feel
free to have a pause here
uh and have a play around in your
replica boom environment
before we get going just to feel a
little bit more comfortable about doing
stuff
for yourself okay so once you are ready
i think it is fine for us to carry on
let's
do it let's start off with space
invaders best
okay so let's do it let's build space
invaders once again using the kaboom
gs environment in replit so
i'm going to start off with making
another rebel
so once again i'm just going to click
here and i'm just going to click ok
and once again a random name is
generated for me
feel free to change it if you wish or
keep it the choice is up to you
and i'm just going to click create reply
great so now we are here let's
get going the first thing i'm going to
do is actually
start by perhaps creating our map
so just like we did in the intro i'm
going to use the kabum method of add
level
and i'm just going to open up an array
for our map
and an object for our config so now
in here let's start creating our map
so i'm just going to put a few of these
so i think let's have a left wall
and then let's have some space invaders
so
i'm just going to decide that i want the
little hat
to be a space invader so i'm just going
to put a few of these
let's have 10 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 or perhaps more what do you think
let's put a few um the choice is totally
up to us and then some spaces
and then i'm going to have an and sign
our ampersand
for the uh right wall because we need to
tell our code what is going to be the
left wall
and the right wall for collisions
i'm just gonna have three rows of these
space invaders
and the rest is just going to be
a left wall and
the right wall so just like so
i'm gonna have a few of these because
it's gonna be quite a big
board for us so we have a lot of space
to play around with
okay
now let's do our config so i'm going to
decide that i want each
of the elements on my board to let's say
have a
width of let's say 30 and i'm going to
make the height
20
or so or 22 and then
i'm going to define what everything is
on my board so perhaps let's create the
sprites first because we need a
space invader like
so and let's make it width 30 height to
22
and click create so now i'm just going
to create my little space invader guy
once again like please feel free to
make your spins vader look however you
wish
this is how i've chosen to make mine
of course the choice is completely
up to you so similar to like we did
before but here's my
little space invader it's going to give
him some
little eyes
and great so i'm happy with that now i'm
also going to create
a left
wall so perhaps let's just use wall for
this
because we can reuse it and width 30
height 22 and click create and for this
i'm just going to color it
black fantastic
so now let's go to adding our sprites
so i've decided that i want these little
hats to be
our space invader so this is the syntax
i open up an array
and i'm going to use the kaboom method
of sprite
to then find the space invader so i need
to get the space invader by using the
string
of whatever it's called and then
so that is the first one and then let's
also make
a so we decided this we want to be a
left wall
well i can reuse the sprite for wall
so i'm just going to open up an array
and use sprite and then pass
through wall like so even though i don't
know why wall
so we have our wall i'm actually going
to give this the tag
of left wall
so we can use it in our project so left
wall and i'm going to copy this
and then this time i'm going to use the
ampersand and this is going to be the
right wall so just like so
now if i run this there we go
so there are little space invaders
there are walls i can maybe let's scale
this
down a little bit or perhaps maybe let's
just get rid of that because we don't
really need it
and click run
so yeah perhaps let's scale everything
down um
i'm gonna scale everything down just up
here
now i can actually change the scale of
this whole game board by going to kaboom
and scaling it down to just one because
at the moment we are double the size
and clicking run okay so there we go i
think that looking
that is looking a lot better and we can
see our whole
board fantastic the next thing we're
going to do
is add our player so const player
and then using the add method again so
just like we did in the intro
i am going to add the player so this is
going to be a sprite
that is going to be a space ship
now let's go ahead and create our little
spaceship so once again i'm just going
to click
space ship and create it with a width of
30 and a height of 22
and click create now what how should we
make our spaceship let's make it orange
and i'm just going to make it
look a little bit like so please feel
free to of course
make this however you wish
but i'm happy with that so now
i've got my spaceship i'm just going to
get rid of this again
i'm actually going to give it a position
so i want to position it
in the middle of my screen so i'm going
to use width
divide by two and
height also
divided by two just like that
and then oreo
gin the string center
and click one okay so now
my little player is in the center um
i also might want to scale it up if i
wish
i don't think i do at the moment i do
however want to scale my invaders
because i don't want them to take up the
whole
square so i'm just going to do scale 0.7
like so and click run
great so now they are appearing a little
bit smaller
the next thing i want to do is actually
assign keystrokes
to my player so i'm going to do key down
so this is to make our player move left
and if i
click left well what do i want to happen
let's put a function
and find out if i press left
i want to grab the player i want to move
it and then let's have the
move speed so const move
speed and let's say that is 200 so now i
can use the move speed
and put zero and because we're moving
left this needs to be a negative
and let's do the same for moving right
so i'm just going to replace this with
right
and then not make this negative so let's
check that out
if i move or press my little keys
there we go our player is moving left
and
right this is pretty cool
now the next thing i want to do is add a
score so i'm going to do this the first
thing i'm going to do
actually perhaps let's move on constant
to the top of the file i'm just going to
paste it in here
and i'm going to get layers so
in my layers let's open up some our
array
i'm going to have the object layer for
where all my objects are a ui layer
where i can score
store delay swa store the score without
affecting everything on my board and
then i'm just gonna make the default
the object player so if it's not sure
that is the default
layer great now that we have that
let's add our score down here i'm going
to say quant
score i'm going to use the add
method so the kabum method to add
this time i'm going to add the text so
i'm going to start off with zero
and then position and i'm going to just
put in 50
50 to position the score
and then if we want we can scale it up
but let's just see how it looks i'm
going to put it on the ui layer so that
is how we will put it on the
ui layer and finally i'm just going to
have an object
of where the score value is going to be
i'm going to start off with
0. so just like that
so now if i run this we get our score
you can sort of see it it's a bit small
i might actually scale this up so
scale by three just to show you where it
is
okay so now it's a lot bigger you don't
have to keep it the size you can also
move it
if you wish so we've got our score
the next thing i want to do is perhaps
let's start
um moving the
[Music]
uh invaders before we start doing
anything else so like adding a timer
or let's add the let's add the timer
okay so
const timer equals and once again i'm
going to add open up an array
uh i'm also going to start with text
thing zero
and then let's position it so i'm just
going to position it
below the text
the score text let's make it
scale just by two this time
and again i need to add this to the ui
layer
and i'm going to put the
oops
and let's have an object that has the
time which is the time
left so const time left
let's say we want i don't know
14 seconds for now so i'm just going to
put it 14.
we can of course always change it so
there we have that let's click
run so that is
our score and that is our time left
let's actually make our
timer move down in time now so i'm going
to grab the timer
i'm going to use action so that is
another kabum method
and action essentially runs every um i'm
just going to show you the documentation
action actually gets called every frame
so okay
just keep that in mind i want the timer
to so let's get up our curly braces
um it's gravity time is time
so this right here and i'm just going to
make it
decrement by delta time
this is delta time since last frame
so just remember that and now i want the
timer
text to be the timer's
time this is going to be delta time
click run so now it's counting down from
14 as we said we want it to be from 14
seconds
let's perhaps shorten it because that's
too many points
after um that i need so i'm just going
to fix that to a fixed
uh length so two fixed
two
there we go so that is looking pretty
cool that is our timer and of course we
need to write what happens when we run
out of time
so if uh the timer time
is suddenly smaller than or equal
to zero well what do we want to happen
we want to lose so we're going to write
a loose scene in a bit
um or we can write it now sure why not
go to the this is how you go to another
scene go to a lose scene
and take the score with you to score
value so let's go ahead and write our
loose scene
so in here we are in the main scene i'm
going to add a
loose scene just like so and my loose
scene is simply going to be so i'm just
going to use
add and i'm going to
add the text of
the args so augs is anything that we
pass through into this
scene args school
so we're gonna add these score uh as
text and we're gonna let's also position
this urge origin
center um let's make it really big
let's make it scale ten and then let's
put the position
let's also grab the width of the screen
divided by two
and grab the height of the screen
and divide it by two
cool so that is
oops really it so now
i'm just going to make the time a lot
shorter because
i don't really want to wait around for
that long so
great so um we do need to fix this
however i am going to just carry on
because we're not actually adding
anything to the score quite yet
nothing's happening with the score so
we'll go back to this uh in a
bit so i'm just going to leave this as
100 for now while we continue
coding okay so it's just going to keep
uh running from 100
just ignore it for now so we have
that um perhaps actually let's that's
quite distracting i'm just going to
comment that out
so there we go don't forget to uncomment
that out
later but for now i'm just going to keep
it like so
and then comment this out uh too
okay great
now let's get our space invaders moving
left and right
i think um yeah i think that'll be fun
let's do it
so i am going to use
uh for this i'm going to use action so
that's another kabum
method and i'm going to grab anything
with the tag
space invaders so just make sure that
the space invader has
that tag which it doesn't let's go ahead
and add that tag here
so i'm just going to put the tag of
space invader
space invader so anything with the tag
space invader well i'm going to pass
through s for the space invader into my
function
because i want the space invader to move
at a uh speed okay
so what should we make the speed
um const
space well let's just go invader speed
that's
fine and let's just make it 200 for now
so i wanted to move on the x-axis with
invader's speed
so let's do it let's see our space
invaders
move
okay so they're moving they're moving
really fast maybe let's make it a
hundred
but they're moving off the board so this
is why i wanted to have a left and right
wall because i need to write a collides
function so i'm gonna do so like this
i'm gonna get collides and if anything
with the tag space invader
collides with anything with the
left wall or let's start with the right
wall first maybe
the tag right ball well what do i want
to
happen well let's get a function and
find out
i want to change the speed of the
invader speed so i'm gonna get const
current
speed and
for now
let's have current speed as
the invader speed so i can just use
current speed here
and if there is a collision well what do
i want to happen i want to get the
current speed and i want to change it
to negative invader speed
okay so i'm going to change the speed
and i'm going to use every
and for every space invader so i'm going
to grab
all the space invaders and i'm going to
so not only change the direction i want
them to move down
so i'm just going to pass through object
we can call this as the space invader
again if you feel more comfortable so we
could do that
for every space invader well i want this
space invader to move
down so this time i need to affect the
y-axis
and i'm just going to do level down
so let's define level down const level
down and let's say 50.
so let's check it out
ah yes of course this will change so we
need to make this a let
thank you for letting us know
okay great so now we just need to do the
other side perhaps let's make the move
down
more by a hundred and i'm just going to
copy this
and i'm just going to paste it and
change it that if they collide with the
left wall
well i just want the space invader speed
to be not negative anymore
but i still want each of them to move
down so let's try that
okay great fantastic
i still think this should perhaps be
bigger so let's try that again
but it's totally up to you okay you can
make this as hard or as easy as
you wish i'm just going to increase the
board size here because
i think it needs to be a bit longer to
make sure that
our um spaceship
fits in it so
there we go that's better fantastic
so we've got our little invaders moving
down the next thing i want to do
is start spawning bullets
so let's do that now actually perhaps
that's right what happens when the
player collides with the space invader
yeah let's do that so i'm just going to
refresh
if the player overlaps
with a space invader
well once again what do i want to happen
well
i want to go
to the lose scene so once again i'm
going to go to the lose
scene just like so
i'm going to pass through whatever the
score is score
value
value okay so that
should work and also if the
so action if the space invaders suddenly
go too low
so just in case they miss my um
spaceship space invader
what do i want to happen well i'm going
to grab this space invader
so if they suddenly get like below a
certain so obviously they've just gone
off because there's no wall
if they get around here i want them to
um i want us to go to the lucien as well
so if uh the space invaders position
y is suddenly smaller than
sorry larger than the
or equal to than the height itself so
you could do it so it's the whole way or
you could do
height divided by two it's totally up to
you that looks like halfway
to me just about
then we want to again just go to the
loose
scene
fantastic so let's run that and let's
see
how we do so while that is
happening i'm just going to carry on
because i want to spawn
some bullets so perhaps
let's just move this to the top of the
file as well just to keep everything
neat okay so you've done all this
time to spawn some bullets
okay great so we are getting a massive
score show up we've got zero score
um that is looking good as soon as we
collide with the
uh spaceship we go to the losing scene
so let's see because i was passing this
through incorrectly
so that should be it now let's
spawn some bullets so once again
where we have this here
i'm going to do key press
because if we press a key so i'm going
to do if we press the
space bar
i want to spawn a bullet so i'm going to
write a function
called spawn bullet for this just going
to do it up here
function spawn
bullet like so i'm going to pass through
[Music]
the position of the player to p for
player
i'm just going to add a rectangle so i
could do so by using rect so that is
another kabum
method and i'm going to make the
rectangle that big
and then i'm going to position it to
wherever the player is
and then origin
center let's give it a color
so color 2.5 0.5
one
just gonna space this out so it's more
beautiful for everyone
and i'm also going to give it the tag of
bullet for later because we
we need to know if we collide with the
bullet
so there we go that's the function spawn
bullet and if i press
key space i'm going to use that and i'm
going to pass through whatever the
player's position is at the time so
player
position
and i'm just going to well let's do this
for now we need to do add actually
we need to add some position okay
so let's try that
okay so there we go we are spawning a
bullet
now if i want to make that a little bit
higher i could do something like this
see and now the bullet is being spawned
a little bit higher than
me cool
now let's get the bullets to move right
so i'm going to do that
now i'm going to use action so just like
that
to pass through anything with the tag of
bullet to anything with the tag of
bullet that's why we give the bullet a
tag
and b for bullet is what i'm going to
pass through into the function
now i'm going to move the bullet to
grab b and then use the kaboom method of
move i'm going to move it
minus and then we need a bullet speed so
this is the y-axis
bullet speed
let's make it 400. okay so i'm going to
grab the bullet speed i'm going to put
minus so it goes up on our board because
remember
x-axis y-axis now
if i'm just going to destroy the bullet
once it's out of the scene okay
just for performance issues in case it
has any performance issues
so i'm gonna grab if the uh bullet's
position
y position is suddenly smaller than zero
well then i want to destroy the bullet
okay
great so let's try that
oh amazing
and now let's actually write something
for the collision so collides
and i'm going to grab the bullet i'm
also going to grab these
anything with the tag of space invader
and then let's pass through a b and an s
one for bullet and one for
space invader and what do i want to
happen well i want to destroy the bullet
i also want to destroy the space invader
and i also want to add one to the score
so score
value plus plus just use the increment
operator and let's actually show
the uh score value and the text because
we hard coded it as a zero string zero
before
i can also add a cam shape so i'm just
going to do that now
let's shake the camera can shake and
let's run it
so now poor cow shake
come shake
how fun is that amazing
um what's up
these score text is not updating though
why is that
score value right sorry the score value
needs to be the score text
we okay how fun is
that we can of course make the game
harder or easier
um just do it however you wish you can
add more space invaders too
it is completely up to you so now let's
uncomment the timer as well
i'm just going to move the constants to
the top just because
i think that is best practice
and then did we have another one bullet
speed
and then of course please feel free to
tidy this up too
i think that is looking okay though
and click run great uh let's make the
time left
maybe 30. so like i said you can do this
by time
you can do it however you wish you can
add more space invaders you can
uh slow down the bullet speed you can do
so
so much um it really is up to you
let's actually move that timer out a
little bit because i think
so yeah the x-axis i think i said y
before the x-axis let's make it a
hundred
okay great
[Music]
now i'm gonna do one last thing before
we go and i'm just gonna change the
background
to be black so i don't want to clear
color i want a black
background
to run
okay and there we have it we have now
finished our game
it looks really fun like i say this is
just the basics to get you going we've
covered all the functionality that you
need
but it is up to you to really make this
game your own take it to the next level
you know add another level if you want
and more space invaders
um of course add more scenes if you wish
there really is
so so much you can do with this
game uh let's just check that the lose
works and it does
we get the score showing up if our space
invader collides with our spaceship
so that is it um one thing that i would
suggest is perhaps add
a winning scene so if you shoot all the
invaders that's something you can do
uh i've already mentioned adding new
levels that is something we're going to
cover in the next tutorial
so if you want to learn how to add more
levels please stick around
mario up next
okay so well done creating space
invaders now it's time to move on to
creating
mario again in the kaboom replit
environment
as you can see i'm already in my replica
kaboom environment if you have skipped
ahead
to this section i would recommend
watching the basics section
in order to understand how to get to
this point
once again i'm just gonna check that i
am on kaboom version five
if you are on a later version of kaboom
currently
then please do refer to the
documentation if you feel something
isn't working quite right to see what
has been updated
since okay so
great i'm actually just going to start
off with our scale being
one and let's do it
the first thing that i'm going to do is
actually load up my sprites
so in space invaders we drew the sprites
this time i'm going to upload the
sprites so i can do so
in the kaboom replit environment quite
easily just by this button right here
so as you can see i've already created
all my sprites
the next thing i'm just going to do is
click them to
upload them like so
so there we have our block you can see
the name of the file is exactly what
our environment calls our sprite
i can then do a blue brick so just like
so
a blue evil shroom
some blue steel and then
a blue surprise
a brick
a coin
an evil shroom one
i'm not gonna have evil shroom two let's
have mario standing
a mushroom
a pipe left
a pipe right
a pipe top left
and a pipe
top right side so we don't need all of
them
and then a question box
and then an unboxed box so hopefully
that should be
it this is looking good
the first thing i'm going to do is add
my map so let's do it
i'm simply going to write const map
like so open up an array so just like we
did in space invaders
and i'm just going to draw my map how i
envision it for
mario so i think that should be okay
please make sure to keep everything in
the quotation marks
for this to work so i'm just gonna keep
pasting
just like so
okay and then i'm going to create a
ground
i'm not sure which ones i want to use
for the ground but i'm just going to put
the equal signs
as a ground for me for now on and then
perhaps some
spaces too so there we go
that is looking good the
next thing i want to do is decide where
everything else
goes on my little map so i'm going to
have some pipes
here once again i am using symbols which
i'm going to assign
values to in a bit so there is my pipes
i'm also going to have some mushrooms so
what should i use for the
evil shroom sorry let's use these little
things
and then i'm going to have let's say one
two three four one two three
four up here
let's have a coin surprise
and then perhaps some
more bricks so let's
do a brick and then another surprise
this time let's say it's a mushroom
surprise another brick and then
a coin surprise and another brick
so that is looking good i do think we
perhaps need to make this a little bit
wider so i'm just going to add some
length to our grid
okay so just like that you can feel free
to make this as
big or as small as you wish that is all
the button okay so we have
our map let's carry on
now to add this map i'm going to use a
kaboom
method called add level which takes two
things the first is an array which is
our map
and the second is an object that is our
level config
so we already have our map so i could
just pass through that array like so
and then let's do our level config
so i'm actually going to
define our level config up here let's
call it
const level config
you can call it whatever we wish in
camel case i have chosen to do this
and we know that it's an object so now i
can just replace
this with that just like we did with
the map now that we have our level
config we need to do a few things
i need to define how big and how small
so sorry how wide and how high i want
each of these elements on my board
i'm going to say i want each of them to
be 20 by 20
pixels now let's start defining things
so i'm going to use this because i
already know that this is a block
so i'm gonna this is the syntax for
defining what the elements are i'm gonna
open up my square brackets
i'm gonna use sprite just like that and
i'm gonna pass
through the block as that's what i want
here so that is going to be my block
let's carry on defining some more things
while we are at it
so we've got our block i'm going to say
that
the anything with a dollar sign
is going to be a coin
anything let's carry on so we've got
that
we also want to have a surprise
so this is going to i'm going to use the
sprite of surprise
so here we have the surprise
oh do we have the surprise
the question is the surprise so that is
what we
have i can actually should probably even
call this question and not surprise so
quests
just like so and i'm going to actually
say that anything with this sign
specifically is going to be a coin so
price okay
so we've got that and anything i'm just
going to copy this
because i still want to use the same
sprite however anything with
this sign now i want to be a
mushroom surprise um so perhaps let's
make this a little bit smaller for now
because we don't really need it
okay so we've done that
the next thing that i want to do
well i'm just going to probably add all
of these for now that's probably the
easiest thing to do
so anything with this it's not on the
board i want to be
the unbox so i'm simply grabbing the
string of unboxed
and i don't think this needs anything at
the moment
so i'm just going to get rid of that so
we've got unboxed
the next thing i want to do is the pipes
so this is going to be pipe bottom left
or just pipe left actually so we've got
a pipe left
let's also have a pipe
right
i'm just going to move this up
now we need the top pipe parts of the
pipe
pipe top
left side
making sure that it's exactly spelt
exactly the same
and then pipe
top right
side and that is going to be a plus
okay so we've got that we also want to
have an
evil shroom so once again i'm just going
to copy that
and then we have the little hats as the
shrooms
so i'm just gonna say this is an
evil shrimp i have the number one in
there
um we don't have another one for now so
i just have to make sure that i've spelt
it
exactly the same so we've got our evil
shroom the next thing i want
to add is stuff that we don't actually
have yet
so i'm just going to say
that this is going to be a mushroom
we have a bunch of blue things for the
next level but i think i'm going to
leave them
just for now so if i run this now
here we go let's get rid of this
because we want to be able to see our
board
fantastic i do need to scale
some things in order for everything to
fit for the purpose of the tutorial
so i'm just going to get rid of some of
these now
um of course like i said you can make
this as big
or as little as you wish in your free
time
but as this is a tutorial i want to be
able to show you everything
comfortably um so yeah feel free to
make this your own when you can
and when you finished coding along with
me
okay so i think that is much more
manageable
let's carry on
um i'm gonna actually get rid of maybe
one more just just because
i do want everything to fit comfortably
if i'm being honest
okay
okay
okay
so that's looking a lot better now i
don't want these to be these bricks and
i want to scale these so i've done this
on purpose so that i can show you how to
scale sprites
directly from the config
so i can now use scale 0.5
on all pipe related things because all
the pipes seem to be too big
so i'm going to scale each of those and
just click run
and perfect now the pipe is exactly the
size
we wish without having to change the
pixel
the png or the jpeg itself
so that is done one thing i also want to
do is perhaps change
the bottom to be this brick right here
so let's go ahead and do that i'm going
to copy this
and then let's maybe make the brick an
x and call this brick and i'm just going
to replace
so i'm going to use command d to replace
all the bottom
once like so
with an x and hit run
awesome
so now i can change the background as
well
this is something i can do now or later
the choice is up to you
i would simply have to go here and i'm
just going to select the
color and then click
run oops
and there we go
great
so we have our board the next thing i
want to do
is add mario so
i'm going to do so right down here
i'm going to say i'm going to use the
add kabum
method to add a sprite
and i'm going to add the sprite mario
standing because i think that's what we
called our mario
mario standing that's correct so i'm
going to add that
to our board and i'm also going to
position him
so at the moment i'm going to position
him just sort of at the top
here so let's go ahead and click run
and there he is now i want to make him
fall so let's i'm just going to format
this a little bit
neater so it's more readable for
everyone
so i can make mario 4 if i want i can
apply
gravity tomorrow i simply have to do so
by adding the
body component to the array
just like that and there he goes
but we don't really want him to fall
through the
ground right so we can actually prevent
this by making the
ground so the brick solid
so now if i click run it stops
so while i'm here i'm just going to
decide what else i want to be solid
i definitely want the brick to be solid
and i want all the
pipes to be solid too
so i'm just definitely going to make all
of these
solid like so i'm going to make the evil
shroom solid
too as well as the blocks
themselves and anything with
the sprite question so
a whole bunch of solids there
okay great so we have done that now
um i'm just going to move this out so
you can perhaps
read it a little better that's that's a
lot more readable
okay so we've added our player the next
thing i'm going to do
is add a score and a level
so i'm going to do so up here i'm going
to add
so once again using add it's got
parenthesis and an array
i'm going to just space it out a bit so
it's more readable
i'm going to put text and i am going
to just put in a 0 for now
which we will solve at the end but i'm
just going to hard code it
just for now and let's position it on
our board so sort of at the top
so this is the x-axis if you remember
from our previous lessons
and this is going to be the y-axis just
from this point
right here so now that i've added that i
want to make sure that this won't
interfere with our pacman and won't
interview with our game
so i need to add this to the ui layer
which we have not yet added but i'm
going to do that
now so just
up here i think which is the first thing
that we should
do i'm going to define our layers
so that is a kaboom method i'm going to
open up
my parentheses and pass through an array
and in it i'm going to pass through all
the layers that we want
so i only really want an object layer
and a ui layer for this game
and i want to make the object layer the
default so if something doesn't have a
layer assigned
it goes to the object layer so
that should be it the next thing
i want to do is actually pass through a
value for the score
so i'm going to put value square
value if i can only spell it
and once again we don't really have a
score just yet so i'm just going to
hardcord it as zero
just so we can see it now um let's
actually save this so we can reuse it so
i'm going to
save it as the score label
just like so great
so we've added the score label the next
thing i'm going to do is actually add
something for the levels itself
so once again i'm just going to use the
array
and pass through the kaboom method of
text
and it's a string that is going to tell
us what level it is so
level
great and i'm just going to pass
through again i'm gonna hard code a zero
for now
we won't uh leave it like this don't
worry but we don't have any levels to
pass through at the moment and then
let's position it
so x-axis y-axis
from the top and then we just need to
make sure that that is in its
in parenthesis and that is in
parenthesis
okay wonderful so we have our score and
we have our level zero
showing up let's move on
now let's actually assign
so i'm going to save this as cons player
so we can
reuse it in our code the next thing you
want to do is make sure that our player
can move
so i'm going to use key down to do this
just like we did in the previous
lesson so key down i need to pass you
two things a string of which key is
pressed on our keyboard
and a function as to what happens if we
press that key
so if i press the key left well i want
to grab the player i want to use the
kaboom method of
move and i want to pass through an x
axis and a y
axis and because i want them to move
left well it's going to
be this one right here so i could say
120
or i could assign a move
speed to mario so let's make that 120.
so now to move left i need to make sure
this is -120
and we don't want anything to happen in
the y-axis
so i'm just going to pass through a zero
okay
so let's check it out
so now if i press the left key what is
going left
so now let's do it for the right side so
i'm just going to copy this
and i'm going to make this right and i'm
just going to make this not negative so
he's moving
120 on the x-axis
so now let's check it out and great
the next thing i want to do is for um
married to jump
so this time i'm going to show you how
to use key press
it's exactly the same i if i pass
through
a space fast with a string of space or
what do i want to happen
let's write a function
now i can make our player jump
so i can grab player and use jump so
that is a method
and i can pass through a
jump force so let's make this
300 from now i'm just going to put it in
there
so now if i run this and i press space
there he goes he's jumping a bit too
high for my liking without a mushroom so
i'm just going to change this to
150 instead and see how that looks
that is much too small let's try 200
let's try it 300
and finally let's just try it 360. i
think that should be okay
okay great so your jumps just high
enough to hit these but not high enough
to um
i guess we don't want that double jump
either
but not high enough to get onto the next
level so that is fine let's get rid of
the
uh double double jump
so we only want him to jump if the
player is grounded so that is another
kaboom method we can use so only jump
so that will get rid of the double jumps
great
now i want um essentially stuff to spawn
if i hit the question mark so these
surprise boxes
so where should we do that let's just do
that below here i'm going to move these
to be at the top of the file
just purely because i think it's much
neater
so i'm going to grab that and i'm also
going to grab the
move speed great
so now i'm going to grab the player and
on
if there is a head bump so again this
is a kaboom method
well i want so this is a function which
i've actually passed through an object
through and this will make sense in a
bit
whatever object we collide with
is and then let's use the tag of
coin surprise that we made so we've
already made this
as you can see it's here so anything
with this
it has the tag of coin surprise if the
object that we collide with is a coin
surprise
well i want to essentially
spawn a coin so i need to do
i need to assign the level so i'm going
to assign the game
level in order for this to work so i've
assigned
the level to game level
now we need to grab the game level and
i'm going to use the method of
spawn to spawn
a coin so do we have a coin here we do
have a coin it's the dollar sign
so i'm going to spawn a coin and where
do i want to spawn a
coin well i want to spawn it whatever
the object that we collide with
and then i'm going to use grid position
of that object
sub and if we just pass through a zero
i'm going to show you what happens
so i think this is a coin surprise so
the coin appears
um directly on the object
i don't want that i want it to be above
the object so i'm gonna pass through a
one
let's try again
boom okay so it appears above the object
so this is looking great the next thing
i'm going to do is actually destroy
the object so i can do so like that that
is the kabum method i'm passing through
the object i've just collided with
to destroy it so i want to destroy it
but i
also want to replace it so this is how
you'd replace you'd use the game level
spawn
and i want to replace it with
unboxed so i'm going to grab that
and i'm going to pass through the string
of unboxed and then i'm going to
position it
well we've already done this exactly
where
the other object is so i would just do
position
sub zero zero let's give it a go
boom how good is that nothing will
happen here because that's a mushroom
surprise
but that is the coin surprise too so now
that we have that i'm actually going to
copy all of this and just reuse it
if object is mushroom
surprise i want to spawn a mushroom
which is this right here
so i'm going to spawn that and let's run
it
so now ah
no i want to spawn the mushroom here
sorry and replace it with
good that we checked that otherwise we
get both
there we go great now we also want the
mushroom to move right otherwise how we
ever gonna get
mario to grow so i'm going to
move the mushroom to do this i'm going
to use action
and this runs every frame second and i'm
gonna grab
anything with the tag of mush room
so let's just check that has a tag of
mushroom
so let's just give this a tag of
mushroom as it doesn't have one
so i'm just going to give it the string
of mushroom like so
now anything with the tag of mushroom
well what do i want to happen to it
let's write a function and find
out just get rid of that so
anything with the tag on mushroom we're
going to pass through m for mushroom
and i want to move it so as soon as we
see the mushroom
i want to grab the mushroom and i want
to move it on the x-axis so
let's move it at 20 and then we don't
want anything on the y-axis
so let's give that a go
and if i hit this
there we go our mushroom is moving but
it's not falling
we need to change that so i'm also
going to apply gravity to it
just like we did with mario
so now
here we go our mushroom is
falling this is looking great
okay so now it's time to make mario big
if he eats a mushroom
so let's do it now
i'm gonna do so right here so i'm gonna
write my own
function i'm gonna say call it function
big
and in it i'm gonna start a timer let
timer start off with zero
and then i'm going to return
up date
if is
big so we also need to make sure that
he's big here let is
big equal true actually false to start
so it's forced to start
if he is big however well then i
want to get the timer and just
keep minusing delta time from it delta
time
is i'm just going to show you now on
kaboom js
delta time is the delta time since last
frame said i was a good one
to know i'm going to minus that and then
if the timer is suddenly smaller than or
equal to
zero well then i want to
make mario small again so this smaller
fight which is something where we're
gonna
write soon so if he's big i essentially
want the timer to start counting down
and if the timer reaches zero
or less than zero we turn him back to
being
small great now
is big i'm just going to return
is big
so if we use that later well you'll see
what i mean when we use it later
and this is where we write smallify as
well that we used above here
and to make mario small what do we need
to do well we need to make sure that his
scale
is uh one as opposed to anything else so
i'm just going to pass through
a one and then i'm going to start off
the
timer i'm going to make sure the timer
is at zero again and make sure that is
big
equals false okay so we've written
smaller phi
now let's write biggify
figure five and essentially
i just need to get all of this right
here
and then this scale let's make him times
two and is big is true
and then we just need to define a time
so whatever we pass through in to
biggify is going to be
exactly how long mario stays big for
okay so that time gets passed down to
the timer
it probably doesn't make much sense now
but promise me when we use it
it will so now i can add big
to the player itself next
i am going to write what happens when
the player actually collides with the
mushroom
so i'm going to write player collides
and then i'm going to pass through the
tag
of mushroom so anything with the tag of
mushroom
if our player collides with it well what
do you want to happen
let's write a function so into the
function i'm going to pass through
m for mushroom itself
and if our player collides with the
mushroom i want to get the player
and i want to use biggify so the exact
thing that we wrote whoops big
gif phi and i'm gonna pass through
so if i pass through a six
well our player is going to be big time
big for six seconds and then he's going
to be turned back to small so a normal
scale
of scale one i also want to destroy the
mushroom
so i'm going to use the kaboom method of
destroy and pass through the m
for mushroom so let's check it out
so now i'm just going to hit that
see i can't do anything with them yet
and there we go i am now
big and then i should turn small
and there we go so now i am big
this is looking good um i
also want to write what happens if the
player collides with
so player collides with
a coin so anything with a tag of coin
just need to make sure that the coin has
a tag it does not so let's just give it
a tag
so if the player collides with anything
with the coin
i just want to add to this score
so i'm going to grab this score label
value
and use the increment operator to add
one to it
and i'm also going to grab the score
label
text and just assign it whatever the
score labels
value is so let's check it out
that should be solid um i obviously
can't jump high enough now
but let's try get a mushroom and get a
coin
so that is i am my score is increasing
as you can see
however i also need to destroy the coin
now
so c for coin so we can't keep getting
more and more points right there's only
one coin we need one score
so now let's try that out again
we get one point um this should be
solid so let's also make the
unboxed solid by passing through solid
like so
great so that is looking better
the next thing i want to do is make our
little evil mushrooms move
so i'm gonna do that down here
here i'm going to grab anything with a
tag of
dangerous so we need to assign
dangerous to the evil shroom so i'm just
going to give it the tag of dangerous
like so
so anything with the tag of dangerous
it's going to write a function to say
what happens i'm going to pass through d
for dangerous
and i'm going to just move whatever d is
for dangerous
um let's give it so this is x and y axis
let's give it an x-axis uh
it's y-axis y-axis we know zero so let's
make it remove
120. so once again i can save this as
something so i can reuse it i'm going to
save it as enemy speed
and make that 120. so now i can simply
use
enemy speed like so i'm actually going
to make it a negative so they're moving
left as well and i'm going to move this
to the top
of my file just to keep things neat
so now oh they're moving really fast
whoa
that is way too fast i think let's maybe
make them move up
30.
okay so that is better i still think
maybe that's too fast but you know it's
up to you
how fast you want them to move now
so the next thing i want to happen is
when they collide
i don't want them to push okay i want
them to
so i just essentially wanted to go to a
game over
so i'm going to use player collides
again
and if our player collides with anything
with a tag of dangerous
what do i want to happen let's write a
function and find
out so if our player collides with
anything with the tag
of dangerous
okay so this is where we want to figure
out if he
is jumping right because at the moment
if we do we just want to go to
a lose scene so we want to go to a loose
scene and take our score with us and the
score is going to be whatever the score
label
value is so we could easily
do this i'm just going to create
a new scene so i'm going to click here
and add a loose scene
just like that and in here i'm going to
use add i'm going to open an array
and put the text the argument that i'm
going to pass through is
score args
so we just go to a loose scene where
that is really small i can of course
make that
bigger if i want and i can center it so
oreo
gin center
position it grab whatever the width is
of my screen divided by
2 the x and grab the height
and divide over 2 to get the y axis
and i can also scale it so scale it by
10 if i really want
so now
if i collide there we go the score is
huge
this is looking good let's go back to
our main scene
so we have nearly everything
we have
oops
um we have our little mario we need to
write what happens so we can destroy
these little guys too so we don't have
to keep
uh dying so perhaps
yeah let's do that now okay so
i'm just gonna jump over them for now to
get them out the way
oh okay let's just leave it zero so
i'm going to get rid of this again and
make this bigger
so at the moment our player collides
with dangerous and we go to the loose
scene
however we want something we want to
write something to let our javascript
know that we are jumping because if
we're jumping then we don't want to lose
we want to kill
the um anything that is dangerous
so if is jumping this is the equivalent
of writing
equals true i could just simply pass
through the boolean if it's
true then it will execute this
else it will execute
this and go to the loose scene
so i'm just going to get that
so if is jumping is true i want to
destroy
anything with the tag of dangerous okay
great if it's oh yes we have not defined
as jumping sorry that is my fault
i'm going to grab that here and i'm just
going to put let is jumping and make it
equal true to start with
so at the moment it's always going to be
true so
there we go we just need to pass through
a d
and i'm just going to jump and great so
we are destroying
the little mushrooms we are also oh
where did he go he seemed to disappeared
um we can fix that so just in case you
are having that happen to you
find the player
so that's where we add the player this
should fix that happen
so happening so just pass through origin
bot let's try again
so boom boom
and then let's grow bigger great
cool now i need to increase my jump size
right because
you know he's meant to jump higher if he
gets
bigger so i'm going to do that
as well as fixing the is jumping too
so
let's do that first so currently he is
jumping at the jump force of 360.
so we need to increase that to
uh another jump force so we could have
big jump force if we want i'm going to
make this
550. now i'm also going to have a
current jump force which is going to
change
but it's going to start off with the
normal jump force okay
so there we go now in here
if we are smallifying and as big as
false i want the
current jump force just to be
the jump force however is if he's
becoming big or if he is big
i want the current jump force to be
big jump force okay
so let's see if that has worked
so once again i'm just going to kill
these guys and i'm going to get my
mushroom
going to be big
ah oops we okay so we are using current
drone force however
when we press the space bar so let's
find the space
bar and you choose the current jump
force okay because that is now changing
it's now changing from big jump force to
just jump force
so let's try it again it's gonna kill
these guys
gonna be big and that's much better
check out how high we are jumping
and i just wanna make sure that we are
back to our normal jump force
now fantastic so one
more thing before we move on and that is
to make sure
that um he's not always that his jumping
is not always true
so back where we use the spacebar
just above it actually i'm going to use
player and i'm going to use action which
runs every frame second
and just check
so if once again i'm going to use player
and i'm going to use grounded if the
player is
grounded so check that he is
and if he is i want is jumping
to be false and
if player is
grounded and we press the space bar i
want this
jumping to be true okay so if we press
the spacebar and he's grounded then
we want him to jump however if he's just
grounded then his jumping
is false hopefully that makes sense
let's move on now
i'm just going to move this
all the way to the top
but after i define the player
so right here and click run
okay so that is all working now i want
the camera
to follow me if i go to the right
so let's let's go ahead and do that now
so right under here i'm going to grab
the player
and i'm going to use action again so to
check every frame
second and i want to actually um
use camera position so another kaboom
method in order to just follow the
player position so we just pass through
the player position
into the account position i also want to
do one more thing while you're here
and i'm going to say that if the player
position
y-axis is suddenly larger
or equal to the full
death so anywhere like below here is
going to be the full
death then i want to go
to the lose scene as well
and i'm just going to pass through this
score just like we did before so the
score labels
value as the score so now let's define
our for death const for
death and i'm just gonna say 600
okay um i think that's
i think that should be fine let's check
it out
so now just going to fall
and it works and the camera is following
us too this is looking this is looking
good
now let's go to our next level so i want
to go to the next level
if we um actually land on
the pipe right here so let's
do that i'm going to actually do that
towards the
bottom where shall we do it
i guess it doesn't really matter let's
just do it here so i'm going to grab the
player again and if player collides with
anything with the tag of pipe then
what do we want to happen we want to go
to the next
level so let's just check that these
things have
the the pipes sorry have a tag of
pipe themselves they do not so i really
just need to add it to the top one
so i'm going to add it to here
and i'm going to add it to here making
sure that it's in the array
so now when i collide with those i want
to go to the next
game see so let's think about this
i'm just going to go to this for now if
i collide with the pipe but
also if i key press down as that is what
happens i need to keep press
down so if these two things are true if
i'm on the pipe
and then i press key down then i want to
go
to my game again but i want to go to the
next level
so i'm going to pass through level like
so um
and i'm just gonna pass to level plus
one
for now okay so we're going to the next
level and then i'm also going to take
this score with me so scroll
label
value great at the moment i'm just going
to comment
this out for now and let's
let's do our second scene so let's do
that now
so before we get finishing onto moving
on to the next
scene i'm actually gonna make the next
scene as that makes the most
sense so we already have one map
i'm gonna actually
now make an array of two maps
so array of maps is gonna store one map
and a second map
and our first map so this here is just
gonna be
all of this right here so i'm gonna cut
this and then
maybe just space it out a little bit so
it's a bit easier to read
that is now going to be our first item
in our maps array
so there we go maybe format that a
little bit better
and then we just have to make our second
map too
so now instead of passing map along with
the level config
i'm going to get my array and whatever
the first item is in my array
well that's going to return this so
that's if i pass through a zero
i'm getting the first item from my array
if i pass through a one
i'm getting the second item for my row
so let's
make the second map now i'm simply just
gonna copy most of this
really and just paste it in here but
change things around so we use the
blue uh theme this time
so let's do it so what do i want
this time i don't think it should be as
tall
and i'm actually going to use a lot of
the blue
things that we have so i do know that i
want
walls at these sides so i'm just gonna
add those
to the other side too
so just like
that and then we don't want the bricks
anymore so perhaps let's make these
z's i don't think we've used z so i'm
going to use
z's in this level
and then we do want a pipe however let's
have the pipe
at the end this time so it's quite nice
as we actually get to reuse
everything that we done before and we
can also reuse the
logic so again i'm not going to have
these mushrooms i'm going to have some
different mushrooms this time
and my mushroom's going to be this guy
and then i'm just going to delete
these two
and just use a bunch of this time
and then we obviously have
our pipe i also want some
just things we can scale so
so things we can climb scale whatever
you wish to call it
so i'm just going to make those now
um once again please have
all the fun creating this all by
yourself
it really is hours of fun creating these
uh levels
okay so we've now defined some new
things in here
let's get to it
so now we have some z's
well we actually also have some of these
signs as what the
pound sign so i'm just going to leave
these blank for now so we can fill them
out i've got pound sign
we've got a zed what else do we have
we've got an at sign
and we've got a dollar sign and
sorry an exclamation and an s
so now let's have a look here well i
know that i want some blue bricks to be
this so i'm going to say blue
brick and i also know that i want this
to be solid so i'm just going to pass
through solid
do we want a blue surprise
i think we do i don't think we have one
though
so i'm just gonna make a seven a blue
surprise
um i'm gonna also add that in here so
let's make a seven
for a blue surprise
if you wish in fact i'm not going to
bother but if you want to add then
please add um you know how to do that
now with the
coin surprises and so on and so on
so yeah if you want to add that please
do let's add
an evil mushroom so this is the blue
evil mushroom
i'm going to call it blue evil mushroom
um and i'm going to give her the tiger
dangerous so that you comply
all the other logic that we've already
done to it so that is pretty handy
s what do we want s s is gonna be our
blue steel
and i'm also gonna make this solid
and then we also need these
sides so what can we make these
sides what a disease
disease is the floor
so we might have to add something else
for the floor
so i'm just going to do that now
we're going to add this blue block to be
the floor so blue
block and then let's have blue
brick great let's hit run
sprite not far found blue evil
mushroom is not found
blue evil shroom
click run oh
and there we go okay we need to scale
everything to be half because as you can
see it's
very big so let's
do it again i'm going to use scale 0.5
not here but here on anything that is
new
and then we need to make these solid too
so make sure
that everything with a uh
brick is solid
okay we've actually reused this blue
brick so if i really wanted to
um i could definitely change it so let's
maybe do
that
or let's
add some
we could make these blue surprises so
i'm just gonna make a blue surprise
sorry i'm being really
uh indecisive so blue
sir price
and then we can also give this a tag of
coin surprise so exactly what we expect
to happen for a coin surprise will
happen for these just because we gave it
the tag so
how handy is that save just having to
rewrite
so much logic okay
amazing so how cool is that
once again we've pretty much
it's pretty much done everything for us
and if we look here
all the levels will act pretty much
the same way
um cool
so that is looking
good
we definitely die if we hit one of these
so that is good
why are these not sprouting coins though
let's have a look so blue surprise
coin surprise
ah it's because i misspelt it so let's
run that
okay fantastic so much work saved
for us it's incredible right
um okay great we have one more thing to
do
and that is make sure that our mario
goes to the next level
so let's do it okay so what i would do
is this
just like so i would just have to define
a
level okay
so there we go
amazing now we can actually get our
scores
uh sorry our levels to loop
all i'd have to do is find the level
and then i would use modulus
the level length
to make sure that they loop okay so
let's check that out one more time
okay and then
of course make sure that these scores
are passing two
and great so we have now finished the
mario game
this was super fun thank you so much for
coding with me of course please take
this game
i'm sure there's many improvements that
could be made and many improvements that
you can contribute to it too so just
head over to mine if you want and fork
it or just use what you've coded
so far um thanks so much again
and one more game to go
let's do it this time we'll be doing
zelda completely
from scratch
okay so now it's time to start coding
zelda but completely from scratch so
before we were using the pre-configured
kombum
replica environment this time i'm going
to show you how to
use kaboom js so the javascript
library in a index html
and javascript file okay so completely
from scratch
let's do it the first thing i'm gonna do
is actually go back to the kaboom js
page and i'm simply going to
take all of this script just
right here i'm then going to in my
index.html file
so all of that script there's two
scripts there's the first
script and the second script
i'm simply going to take all of it and
just
at the bottom of my two body tags
just paste everything like
so okay so if i run that
now you will see oh hi mark in the
browser
now this is great but i don't really
want to keep all my javascript in here
because at the moment that is what is
happening so i'm just going to cut this
out
so that is all you should see in
the index html file for now and in here
i'm just going to paste the javascript
like so now back in here
instead of having this script tag with
the type module
i'm going to have a script tag and a
closing
script tag with the source
of whatever my javascript file is called
so obviously
at the moment it is game js
just like that and it's in the root of
our project so i don't have to do
anything
i just put the file name like so
um do make sure that it's under the
kaboom
js uh script okay
along with the version okay so just like
that
body tag first script
second script if i get rid of this that
might be a lot easier
to read i'm just going to format it a
little bit
too great so if i run this
nothing should change let's carry on
so this is our index html
file now let's move on to our javascript
file
so once again i'm just going to get rid
of that
okay so this is great however it's not
really our zelda game
so let's start i'm just gonna start from
scratch
once again i need to initiate the kaboom
js environment so i'm gonna do this
get some curly braces and i'm gonna put
global
true um let's make the game
full screen true
scale let's sort of a scale one
let's put debug as true as well so we
get the debug messages
and i'm just going to make a clear
background so i'm going to make it let's
make it
black okay perfect
so now that we have kabum initialized
let's add some
sprites so this is a completely
different way to do it obviously before
we were using
the replica environment where you can
draw the sprites directly in here
however if you are using your own ide
or just doing it on replit from scratch
we can do this so there is a
kaboom method called load sprite
and we simply write it like so now
i have actually stored all my images
online so you can use them as well
when i do projects like this i usually
store all my images on this third-party
service called
imager so if you go to my imager
and look at my posts you can see i've
already made
a bunch of sprites for us for this zelda
game so i'm just going to go ahead and
lift
some now let's get link going left
i'm simply going to get shareable links
i'm going to copy this bbc
code one right here and i'm simply going
to paste
the path to my
sprite i'm also going to name it while
i'm here so i'm also going to pass
through a
string let's say link going left just so
it's easier for me to work with now
i could so there's my first sprite
let's get also link going
right so let's go back here and let's
find link going right
so i'm just going to once again get
shareable link and click this right here
and just go back to here and paste
the path to my link going
right this time so i could keep doing
this but of course this is
very wordy and there is a lot of
repetition
there is another kaboom method called
load route
which will allow me to essentially load
this
route so i don't have to write it each
time so that is a lot neater
let's carry on so you've got link going
left
link going right let's also have
link going down
link going up
left wall
right wall
let's have the top wall
bottom wall and then all the also the
corner walls
so essentially i'm getting everything
that i need to make up my link
game in order for us to create our board
so now let's go
bottom
left wall
bottom right wall
top left wall
top right wall and let's just do these
for now and then we'll carry on in a bit
so link going down i'm just going to go
in here and grab
this little guy copy the link and once
again just
paste it in here simply using
this at the end and then
link going up
so again i am just going to
get share links copy that one
paste it in here but get rid of this as
we already have the
root now let's get the left wall
so this looks like a left wall
to me
once again i'm going to get the share
link copy that
just paste it in here
[Music]
now let's get the right wall
so this to me looks like a right wall
get share links copy
paste that in here
let's find our top wall now
so this to me actually looks like a
bottom wall
it's fine we'll just do the bottom wall
now get share links
copy bottom
wall just like so
and just paste into top
wall okay now let's get the bottom left
wall so this to me looks like a bottom
left wall
let's get the bbc code
so charlene copy
bottom left wall and just get rid of the
which bottom
right wall to me it looks like a bottom
right wall get shell link copy
and just paste it in here
like so now let's get the top left
wall
once again get share links
and now the top right wall
so this should be the last of the walls
we just have some doors and some
enemies to put in so gets again get
share links copy
and just whack that in there
perfect so now we've got all the walls
let's
i'm just going to move that up here for
us we've got a few more things to do
um let's get the
top door
so we're gonna have a top door a
left door
we're also gonna have a fire pot so
that's just gonna be some decorations
really
i'm also going to have some
lanterns
and then let's put in a
slicer so this is the first of our
baddies i guess
skeletor it's not actually skeletal
but looks quite similar so that's how
i've named this little character
some stairs and then let's also have
a background so i'm just gonna go bg for
background
so let's carry on let's get our
top door
so this is my top door get share links
copy
once again it's making sure
just to get the end let's find our left
door
share links copy
it's gonna put it in as a string
along with the name that i gave this
sprite so there we go
fire pots let's find some fire pots
so this is what i called a fire pot get
shell ink
copy
once again get rid of that
lanterns is up next let's get the
lanterns so these are my lanterns
you can see i've got a lot of images in
here all from like various
projects that i have on youtube either
on free code camp or
on my own channel so there we go
let's get these slices so oh
actually let's get skeletor just because
you know he's here
let's copy that let's put that in here
just like so
this is what i called a slicer so get
sherlink
copy
a shelling copy and now for the
background which is going to be a lot
bigger than all these sprites but that
is not a problem
so once again get share link copy
and just put that in
yeah fantastic so we've got all our
sprites
let's move on the next thing i'm going
to show you how to do
is add a scene so this way is different
than we
did before i'm going to show you of
course how to do it from scratch
and from scratch we would use the kabum
method
scene just like so
i'm going to open up a parenthesis and
the first thing i'm going to pass
through
is the name of the scene and the second
thing is going to be a function
so this is where all the magic is going
to happen
so let's call this scene game and i will
be passing
through a level and a score into here
so that with each level we actually get
these score
and move on to the next um level and so
on
as well as as well as the level but we
don't really have anything
at the moment quite yet
because we need to also start the game
so this is another kabum method to start
the game
i would simply pass through the string
of what scene i want to start
as well as anything else so as i already
said i want to pass through the level
and the score into the
uh game scene so to start with i'm
simply going to say that the level is
zero
and the score is also zero
okay so if we run that we won't really
see
anything because um we haven't actually
written any logic but that is sort of
what you need to do to get started so
for now i'm just going to
define our maps
so let's do that first so once again
i've showed you how to do this now
however i am gonna just comment it out
until we need it and until we you know
start working with the level unscore so
i'm just gonna comment this out like so
great so at the moment we are not
passing through anything into the game
now as i said the first thing i want to
do is define
our maps so let's start off with the
first one first
const map now
i need to draw my actual map so to do
this
i'm just going to make everything in
these quotation
marks and i'm just going to decide
what i want as all my sprites
so let's just for now
i'm just gonna show you what i mean so
one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten and then
let's make it ten by ten
three
four five
six seven eight nine
and one more to make it ten
okay so one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten
amazing and i just need to put a comma
after all of
these
two great so for now i'm just going to
put c's
in here um just to show you
how this would look
okay so we've got our map now
we need to use a another kabum method
called add level and into add
level making sure to spell it camel case
we need to pass through two things
the first is our map as an array
and then the second is our level config
as an object
so we already have a map defined so i'm
just going to pass through a map
and then our level config now i can
actually define the level config
here it might make things neater as it
is going to be quite
chunky so our level config
is going to look like this so we did say
it's an
object so now i could just remove this
and just pass through level config and
our object
is going to look a little bit like this
so in here we're going to define how big
each of these symbols are going to be on
our board
so i'm going to say that each one is
going to have a width of
let's say 48 and a height of
48 pixels just purely that's because
that's how big i actually made my pixels
on
imager okay
and then i'm going to say that anything
with c
is going to be and this is the syntax so
i open up an array
i use the kaboom method of sprite
and then in here i'm just going to pass
through
the string of top wall okay
so this string of top wall is equivalent
to the sprite
which i uploaded above
so now i'm saying that anything with the
c is going to be
a top wall on my map
so now if i actually run this
well there we go we can already see
our map now i can make this a bit
smaller just so
it's easier to work with and there we go
okay maybe just make us a tiny bit
bigger
so now you will see that all my walls
are the top wall
so i don't want this let's actually go
to actually drawing our um
our zelda map correctly so
back in here
so we've already defined uh the top wall
as c
let's do a
sprite
left wall
b
sprite right
wall making sure to spell all these
strings correctly
of the sprites that you imported so
we've got
our left wall right wall top wall
i'm just going to copy this out to make
it a little easier let's make d
the bottom wall
and then maybe let's use something else
for the corner ones
so let's make uh
w the top
right one
x the bottom
left wall
why the top left wall
and let's make z the bottom right wall
okay
let's copy that now
so let's actually use that first perhaps
or let's just do
all of them first what should we do
let's just import all of them to use and
then we can use them to uh
draw our map so let's use these symbols
now because you don't have to just
use uh the alphabet let's also do the
left door just like that
let's also have
um this little hat could be the top door
let's have some stairs
let's also have this slicer which we
make our slicer let's make him
this little guy slicer
and then
skeletal can be
this
so sprite scaler
and then let's have our
let's have some lanterns in too and then
just the fire pot
lanterns
and our fire pot let's make the fire pot
the other way
fire pot
fantastic so we've done
all of that let's also add our um
let's add our background while we're
here so i'm just going to do that down
here
i'm going to use add and then i'm going
to
open up my array so just like we did
with the sprite
above i'm going to find the background
so i saved it as bg
and then i'm going to say the layer it
belongs in
is on the background because i don't
want it interfering with any of my
objects
and i don't want interfering with any
sort of words i put on
so let's actually define the layers
first so we already know we've got a
background layer
let's do that up here
so just under where i uh use the scene
method i'm going to say layers i'm going
to define the layers
so i'm going to have three layers in
this game i'm going to have a background
layer as we've already discussed
and then also going to have an object
layer for where all my objects and all
my enemies and my players are going to
be with
and then i'm also going to have a ui
layer so that these layers can't
interfere with each other
okay we can't collide with them um
they're very separate
and then my default so if something
doesn't have a layer
it's going to be the object layer great
so now if i run this
well there you go the background is
added
let's now get to using all of these on
my map
so we already know that this is going to
be
the left wall so i'm just going to use
command d to change all these to an
a and then let's change all these
to the right wall
so i might as well just make them all
bees
for now
and then the bottom well actually i i
know this is the bottom
left and then what's the top left is a y
and then we've got the bottom right
that's a z
and then top right is a w
and what is the bottom wall well that's
all d so i'm just going to go d d d d d
d like so and then let's also perhaps
put our lanterns in here
so i'm just going to put that in here
and i'm going to have
a door um
just like so and there
great let's also have a left door here
so i'm just going to perhaps put that in
here
i think i've got one too many levels i
only want this to be nine
high so let's go ahead and delete that
that should be
fine one two three one two three okay
and
let's put in some more lanterns at the
bottom
so i'm going to put in a
lantern here lantern here
and we're missing the corner one bottom
right is
a z great and then i'm also going to put
a
slicer so this was my slicer here
and this slicer
here as well as some fire pots because
you know fire pots are always fun
so let's put this in the center
of our game
i'm just going to put one here and one
here and let's let's have a look at what
that looks like i'm not sure that is the
center but we will soon find
out so i'm just going to run this and
there we go
how good does that
look okay we did pretty well this one's
incorrect though
bottom left wall this should just be an
x my
bad amazing
okay this is looking awesome i'm super
pleased
with it let's carry on
so we've defined our layers we've added
a map
the next thing i want to do is add my
little
zelda so let's do that here
okay so i'm going to use the kaboom
method of add i'm going to open up my
parentheses and once again
get my square brackets
and in here i'm actually gonna get
sprite once again and i'm going to just
start off with link going left
so i'm going to grab the um
string of link going left so that is the
sprite
that we imported above
and the next thing i want to do is just
assign a position
to it so i can use pos for position like
so
and then i'm just going to make him go
left so this is where we start positions
from
left 5 and down 190.
so you should be somewhere around here
great so now if i run this
well there he is maybe let's have him
going right actually so i could just
switch this
out and there we go so he's sort of on
the door
at the moment the next thing i need
to do is actually
make our little sprite move so perhaps
let's do that first to make things
easier i'm going to assign all of this
code to const player
so we can keep reusing it throughout the
game
so now i'm going to use key down
so this is one that we've used in the
previous
lessons and if we press key down and we
press the left
key on our keyboard where we want
something to happen right so i'm just
going to put in a function
here so the string of what key
followed by a function of what's going
to happen that's what the key down
or key press um kaboom method
takes so if we press key left
well i want the player to move
and then we need to define a speed
so i'm going to perhaps define that here
we could just pass through a number
but to make it all reusable i'm going to
define a speed for us here
and i'm just going to call it move
speed and then let's make it 120 for now
let's see how that goes
so i'm gonna say when he's moving left
well we have to grab the move
speed and make it negative with the move
kaboom method the first thing we pass
through
is the x-axis and the second is the
y-axis
so in this case i want the y x to be
zero i don't want anything to change on
the y-axis
but i do want something change on the
x-axis i want them to go
left so that is how we would do that
so there we have it we have key down
left
let's also have if we move
right well then we want to just simply
move at the
move speed
and then let's also have up
and this time you guessed it this has to
be
zero and this is going to be the
move speed but this one's also going to
be a negative
and then finally we have the
key down move down in which with this is
not a negative
it just looks like this
so now if we run the game there we go
a little sprite is moving
now we can also do a change sprite which
is something that we didn't cover
in the previous games
but i think is quite fun so i'm gonna do
that
now when we go left
i want to grab the player and i want to
use
a method called change sprite to change
the sprite
to whatever other sprite we imported
so in this case i want to change it to
link going
left okay
and let's do the same for the others
this one's going to have link going
right
and then let's have link going up
and link going down
so just a reminder i'm simply using
all of these here to change the sprite
to these
if we press on the keys so
now here we go
that is looking so good i think we are
ready
to move on okay
now the next thing i think we should do
is move our little
slices so let's do it for this i'm just
gonna
gravitate down here to do our slicer
game logic
so this time well
i need to
i'm going to use the kaboom method of
action because i'm going to
grab anything with the tag of slicer
and then let's get our function up so
there is
obviously a pattern here we usually pass
through a string and then a function
into most of these
kabum methods and what do i want to
happen to these slicer
well to every slicer so s for slicer
or everything with the tag of slicer i
should say so perhaps let's um
go up here and i'm just going to give
slicer the tag of slicer
like so so now everything with the tag
of slicer
well i'm going to grab the slicer i'm
going to move it
now i can move the slicer once again x
and y
axis but i actually want to um
change the direction of the slicer i
want him to bash into the wall
and then change direction when he bashes
into war because at the moment let's
define a const slicer
speed let's make it 120. if i put
through the slicer speed here and just
keep this zero
and run it our slices are moving
but they're just carrying on this is not
what i want
so let's fix this to do this i'm going
to go back up here
because i need to give all my walls and
everything that i want to essentially be
solid
on the board the component of solid
so in here i'm essentially
going to on all the
walls i'm going to give them the
component of solid
i'm also going to give them the tag of
wall which you will see why
later but we essentially want to treat
all of these as
walls just like
so so we've got a few more to treat as
walls
and to treat as solid so
there we go that is looking good while
i'm here i'm also going to make the
lanterns solid because at the moment
we can move through them i don't want
this
so let's make the lanterns solid
2 oh and the
fire pots so that was actually
solid so that was actually a fire pot
these are the lanterns but we need both
to be solid really so there we go
that is looking good we can also assign
the lantern the tag of wall
just in case because we want it to be
treated like a wall
essentially great
so we've done that now while i'm here
i'm also going to give our
slicer a direction so i'm going to start
off
with the direction of the slicer being
minus one
okay we can add any sort of object we
want in here it's sort of like a storing
value so i've just chosen
to store dir minus 1 which i know
is for direction so now that we have
that
let's carry on so we have our slices
moving off let's just check we can't go
through the last lantern
uh we can go through the lantern okay so
to fix this
i can actually fix this i just need to
resolve the player
so what i would do so just after i've
added the player
just here i would use player
action
and then grab the player and resolve so
that should
fix the issue of the player going
through things that are solid
so let's try that perfect so now we
can't go through anything
that is solid great
okay so now that the slices have a
direction and they're moving off
i actually want them to change speed
change direction sorry
when they hit anything with the tag
of war so let's do it
so just here i am going to
use the kaboom method of collides
just like so and anytime
anything with the tag of slicer collides
with anything with the tag of
wall once again let's write our function
and the slicer so if that happens and if
both collide
i want this slicer dur to change
to minus there so if this is currently a
positive it will change your negative
and if it's a negative it will change to
a positive
maths so that is happening
and that should change the direction
however now that we have that
i need to make sure that that is being
applied here so i can use
s direction and multiply it so whatever
s direction is at the moment if it's a
minus
one i will multiply it to 120 which will
make that
which will make that minus 120. so
r slider or slicer will move left
and alternatively it's a one where we'll
multiply one by 120
and our slider will move 120 to the
right
so that is cool let's check that out
and we've done it our sliders are moving
and they are literally bouncing off the
walls and changing
direction so this is looking good
let's carry on now i need to write some
code for what happens if we you know
collide with our slider because that's a
bad thing
i want our player to essentially lose so
that is a game over in my eyes
i could do so by grabbing the player and
using
overlaps this time and if our player
overlaps with the
slicer or i could put dangerous
so that means that anything with the tag
of dangerous which means i can reuse
this tag
will result in a player
losing and going to a losing scene
so at the moment i'm just going to
perhaps make a
let's maybe leave this for now because i
need to write this score
so i'm going to apply the tag of
dangerous
to the slicer and i'm also going to
apply it
to skeleton great
now that we've done that i think we need
to start looking at the score because if
there is a loose scene i want to go to
the loose scene
with our final score so let's do it
just under here i'm going to add
so once again open up a parenthesis and
an
array and i'm just going to start with
the text
being a hard-coded 0 just to start off
with
and let's position it on our game board
so i'm going to make it go at the bottom
so x and y axis
and then i'm going to add it to the ui
layer so it doesn't interfere with our
game and i'm just going to assign the
value um the
score so whatever the score currently is
that is the value okay
so because we don't have a score at the
moment i now need to pass
through the score to add start the game
so we're going to start off at zero and
then up here once again i'm going to
uncomment that out
that is being passed into my game scene
and if i run
don't forget to add that comma
now if i run the game you will see a
tiny zero
but it's very small let's scale it up so
i'm gonna scale it up by
four just so we can see okay
so now we've got a score it's obviously
zero um
because we don't have anything yet let's
write our lose
scene and then that should show the
score
so what i would do is simply use the
kabum method of go
and then i'm going to pass through lose
to make a lose scene
and then i am simply going to
get these score and
i'm going to save this as const score
label
so i'm going to get the score and
whatever the score labels
value is that's what i'm going to pass
through
so now let's just collide with one of
these
check that's working
we haven't actually written our seen so
let's go ahead and do that so we should
go to a loose scene
with the outside of our game scene i'm
going to create the loose
scene now so our loose scene is going to
look like this so once again a string
and then a function of what's gonna
happen
and for this i'm just gonna pass through
the score or whatever this
is so i'm passing that through d
structured
and then i am going to add
so once again parenthesis
square brackets i'm going to use the
kaboom method of text
to pass through the score and the
position
of where i want to position it let's
make the origin
be center so i'm going to pass through
the string of
center and then let's position it
i can actually grab the whole width
of the browser window and divided by two
and then
grab the height as well
and divide by two as well so now if i
run the game
go ahead and lose so
amazing we get zero showing up in the
middle of our screen because that is our
current score because we have
no score great so
i think we've done everything we can on
this level
let's now try to add a new level
so let's do it
great so we have our map here
now i need to add two maps so for the
first level i want to go to this map but
if it's the second level i need to go to
you know the second map so const map i'm
going to rename to
maps and then this is going to be an
array
of arrays so i'm going to have two
levels at the moment
and i'm simply going to grab all of this
and work that in
here
so there we go and just get rid of that
so now if i want to go into the first
map where i'm going to grab the maps
array and whatever level we are on this
is why we started the level on zero
i'm gonna go into the maps array and if
the level is zero
i'm gonna grab the first
map so i can just simply pass through
level
like so and that will do the same thing
okay so that way i'm literally getting
the first
item of my maps array which is that and
now let's make our
second level so i'm just going to paste
this here
and let's do it so for my second level
i'm pretty much going to keep it the
same let's perhaps get rid of some of
these things and i'm going to have
lanterns on this side now just to make
things a little bit different
let's get rid of these slices let's get
rid of the
lanterns i'm just going to make these
a straight wall now in here i'm going to
have some
stairs and then i'm also gonna have a
skeletor great
so now let's just change our level to be
one for now
that is our second map amazing
so i actually want to get rid of this
door too so let's just connect with that
door
like so great
now how do we get from level one to
level two well i'm going to show you
that
now so down
here i'm actually going to give my top
door
the tag of next level
just like
so and in here
so perhaps let's do it down here i'm
gonna say if player
overlaps with anything with the tag of
next
level what do we want to happen let's
write our function
and find out so if that happens
i want to go to the game scene again so
we are currently in the game scene
but i want to go to the scene again and
pass
through level
i'm just gonna pass through level plus
one to get to the next level
and then the score so whatever the score
labels
current value is i want to pass
through okay so let's check
that out let's go back to
level zero now let's try
collide or sorry overlap with the door
making sure the slider is out the way
first
and great if i try however go here
nothing will happen
i need to add next level to the stairs
too this will however be problematic
so i'm gonna show you why so
just let that collide again
now if i go to the stairs everything
breaks
that is because there is no level three
so i can easily account for this by
um it's finding a level
and then i could say modulus
maps length to make
the levels loop over each other okay so
this way it will loop
um and it will just be continuous
for us so now if i go here
go up the stairs you will see it's
looping
so that is just a quick fun fix for you
let's carry on i should really be moving
this to the top
of my game so just to keep everything
consistent
let's put this slice of speed up there
too
i'm also going to define my skeletal
speed while i am here
so i'm going to do that now
let's say skeletor so scala
for speed i'm going to make a move quite
slowly so
i'm going to say 60. now
let's i'm going to actually put this
back to level
one just so we can start off on the
second level
each time great so
just where i move the slicer
i'm going to move my skeleton so i'm
going to use
action again and i'm going to pass
through the string of
skeletal this time and well what do i
want to happen
let's write a function and find out so
this time i'm going to pass through s
for skeletal i'm going to grab skeletal
i'm going to move him
and skeletal again let's make him move
up and down this time so i could just
pass through a zero
and the skeletal speed because obviously
x-axis y-axis
but i also want my skeletal to change
direction however this time i wanted to
change direction
randomly and if he hits a wall so i'm
going to show you how to do that
once again i'm just going to up
here give
skeletor a direction
so now
when we move skeletal we also
need to
multiply them by skeletal's current
direction
okay so we are doing that
let's carry on so now i'm going to
actually give skeletor
a timer i'm going to use the
delta time so delta time
if we look here once again
i think i have gone through before but
just one more time
it's the delta time since the last frame
so that's what i'm going to be
using um and if
the timer
so i of course need to give skeletal a
timer up here
so i can do that in the same object
timer
let's start off with the timer being
zero
if the uh timer is suddenly
smaller than or equal to zero
i want to grab the direction
and i just want to change it so just
like we did with
the slicer i'm literally changing it
from a positive to a negative value
and if it's negative to a positive value
and then i want to get these
skeletal timer and randomly
so this is in the method to get a num a
number
randomly between uh 0 and 5.
so now or less than five should i say
now using rand
this will attack assign a new value to
the timer
so essentially this is saying that our
skeletal will change direction
randomly so it will start off at zero
if it's zero then the skeletal will
change direction and then the time is
going to get
another random number from zero to five
and this whole thing will start again
i'm also going to have
i'm also going to have to give skeletor
the tag of skeletor just like slicer
and let's click run okay
great you can see he's changing
direction however he is not changing
direction if he hits a wall
let's do that now so i can
actually reuse this right here so i can
reuse this
and just say that if anything with a tag
dangerous collides with
a wall so dangerous instead of slicer
here we go they should change direction
this is pretty
neat we have a few more things that i
would
like to do so let's
carry on the next thing i want to do
is of course make sure that our
hero can defeat
the enemies so i'm going to do so with a
kaboom
instead of a sword i'm going to use a
big kabum to do this
so first off i'm actually going to have
to
import that sprite so i'm going to use
load sprite again and let's just call it
kaboom
as we are using the kaboom js
environment i thought that was quite
fitting and i'm just going to use this
kaboom that i made here
so i am going to let's refresh
this
i'm going to get the share links copy
this here
i'm just going to paste it as a string
like so so we've got the kaboom now
now we let's actually spawn a kaboom
so i'm going to do this just under
here now i'm going to write a
function called spawn
carbon just like so and
it's going to be a simple function like
this and
into it i am going to
well actually let's start off with
adding what we want to add first if we
spawn a kaboom
because i want to add these sprites of
you guessed it
so at the moment nothing will happen
that's because we need to assign a
position
and the position that i want to assign
it
is going to be the position of whatever
i pass through into my spawn
carbon function okay so
that is what i'm gonna do and then i'm
just gonna give it the tag of kaboom as
we are gonna need that later
and i'm actually gonna save this as
object for now because we are going to
have to
destroy that in a bit so there we
go um let's perhaps write that now
in kaboom we can use the method of
weight
and we simply have to pass through a
number which is how many seconds we want
to wait
before something happens so let's write
our function to write find out what that
something
is so after one second
i want to destroy so another kabum
method
the object which is microboom object
great so we've got everything we just
need to use this function
and pass through a position
so where can we do this well i'm going
to
actually so i'm going to say on key
press
uh spacebar so this is how we would
write spacebar
what do i want to happen let's write a
function
so our function on the key press i want
to use this function that i have just
written
like so and of course we need to pass
something through we need to pass
through position
so the position i am going to pass
through
is my players position so wherever my
current
player is okay
so i think that should work
let's try it out i'm gonna press space
and there we go
this is looking pretty cool
however let's actually position it um
a little bit farther than our player
so where is our player where we add our
player
so here we add our player i'm just gonna
space this out so it's a bit more
readable so we're passing through a
sprite we'll possibly
position i also want to pass through an
object that is the direction
and i'm just going to put
him going right at the moment
and i can now use this in order to make
our kaboom uh object
go out a certain way based on his
direction so based on my
player's direction and i would simply
use the position that we are currently
in plus add
so we're going to add a little bit extra
so whatever the player's
direction is and scale it by
let's say 48 okay so 48 pixels if it's
negative 1
it's going to be negative 48 if it's
positive one it's going to be 48.
so that should work the only thing we
need to do is actually assign a
direction to our player each time he
changes direction
so i'm going to go player and then this
is going to be vector 2.
um zero one this is going to be
player direction zero
minus one
and you probably guessed it by now this
is gonna be player direction
one zero and this is going to be
player direction minus one
zero so let's check it out
boom so you will see the kabum is now
not on
the link link the player himself but in
front of him
depending on which direction he is
so great one last thing i promise
and that is adding a score if we destroy
a skeletal so i'm going to
do that here so i'm going to use
collides
again and i'm going to pass through
anything with the tag of kabum
and anything with the tag of skeletal
and i'm going to actually pass through k
for goodbye and the skeletal this time
so we can use both
if both collide well i want to wait
perhaps one second
and then what do i want to happen so a
function
well i want to destroy
the kaboom so destroy the
kabum after one second but i want to
destroy
the skeletal immediately so that is how
i will do that
i can also grab the score label value
and increment it using the increment
operator by one
and then also we can update the score
label
text to be the
score label value just so we can see it
in our browsers
as well okay so that is good and i can
also add something fun
like a clam shake so let's add a cam
shake
of scale four so now let's try it out
boom great so we're getting the cam
shake
we are destroying skeletor and we are
adding one to the score
and if we move on to the next level so
let's just see
this is all let's just try again
so let's just go boom whoa
that was a bit fast let's just try again
boom
amazing everything is looking great
so i hope you've enjoyed making this
game of zelda completely
from scratch please do share your
replies with us on free code camp i
would absolutely love to see
how you have made this game your own how
you have taken it to the next level
um have you added more levels perhaps
have you added more enemies have you
done
any other really cool stuff i'd really
like to know
so thanks so much again for coding with
me i hope you've enjoyed
this lesson and i'm sure i'll see you
soon on free code count
bye
now we've been creating our games in
replit and it is now time for me to show
you
how to publish your games in the replit
app store
too so this is really simple it's going
to be a really short section
if you're really proud of your game and
you want to share it and publish it
please head over to
replit forward slash apps and simply
click
publish right here
once you have clicked this just click
continue
and then search for your repl of choice
i'm going to choose zelda and i'm simply
going to
write a quick description so a wonderful
game of zelda making sure to spell that
correctly
and then if i want to have a cover image
i of course can
i do think that is the best practice i'm
not going to show you how to do that
because i think it is
pretty self-explanatory you can also add
tags so
i've always got html in here i can also
put
kaboom if i wish um and then i can allow
for comments if i feel comfortable to do
that
and there we go it was really that
simple
um thanks so much again for coding with
me
i hope you can share your games with us
too can't wait to see them
now before you go i just want to make a
very quick section about
how to perhaps use kabum in your own
code editor of choice so i'm going to do
this
envious code i hope you can code along
with me let's
do it so this section is really simple
it's going to take a few seconds i'm
simply going to head over kaboom js
and i'm going to copy all of the code
that you see
right here so it's simply this
it's just the code that i'm going to use
for the quick start i'm going to copy
that
and then just post it in the index html
now if i open this up in my code editor
of choice so open up around the browser
you will see the ohiomark text
that we expected to see done it was
really that simple
and from then on you are more than
welcome to use all the other
kaboom js methods to your disposal
don't forget to check what version you
are on so you can see the version here
as most stuff does change quite
frequently so make sure to refer to the
documentation if you are currently on
a newer version you can also move
out all of this into a separate
javascript file
so i would do so like this i would
simply create a javascript file like so
and just paste everything in there
so now if i look at the browser
everything works the same
so it was really that simple thanks so
much for this short section
and i'll hope to see you soon
okay and that's it thank you so much for
coding with me
i hope you really enjoyed this wonderful
course on kaboom js
and i hope you can see how powerful of a
tool it really is
when it comes to game development thanks
so much again
and i'll see you on free code camp soon